the NRA it's one of the most powerful
lobby groups in the United States and
before it fought against gun control it
actually supported it for almost 100
years so how did the NRA go from
supporting gun regulation to from my
cold dead hands hey guys this is Sonia
and this Sunday on aj+ we're gonna look
at the history of the NRA and gun
control in the United States and Lee
Fang from the intercept will be joining
me to discuss how the NRA might be more
interested in gun sales than gun rights
we know that the gun industry wields
incredible influence over the NRA the
NRA likes to portray itself as simply a
membership driven organization the NRA s
political advocacy and their marketing
campaigns are fully integrated into the
gun industry and their political agenda
[Music]
the history of gun regulation in the
u.s. is a history tied to racial
discrimination and the NRA was a central
part of that founded right after the
Civil War the NRA was mostly a sports
club dedicated to promoting marksmanship
but even then it had a hand in policy in
the 1920s the NRA was part of drafting
the Uniform Firearms Act which was model
gun legislation for states to adopt the
act required a license to publicly carry
a gun a license that could only be given
to someone deemed suitable with proper
reason and you can guess who didn't fit
those requirements not too long after
that the NRA endorsed the first federal
gun control act the National Firearms
Act which targeted so-called urban crime
which then was synonymous with Italian
Americans fast forward to the Civil
Rights era the Black Panthers were
openly and legally arming themselves in
the streets of Oakland California
elsewhere Malcolm X was talking about
the ballot or the bullet and of course
these famous words bring about the
freedom of these people by any means
necessary and generally there was
growing unrest over racial inequalities
so in response to the Black Panthers who
were exercising their right to armed
self-defense then Governor of California
Ronald Reagan with the support of the
NRA restricted its open carry laws with
a Mulford Act of 1967 that act banned
the open carrying of loaded weapons and
a year later there was a federal gun
control Act of 1968
now the 60s had seen a slew of major
political assassinations Congress with
the support of the NRA passed the Act it
became the primary federal law
regulating firearms barring mail-order
sales of rifles and shotguns and
prohibiting most felons from purchasing
them but then the 70s happened and the
NRA started changing its tune at a 1977
NRA meeting in Cincinnati a group of
anti-gun controlled members essentially
staged a coup they put their man Harlan
Carter in charge as executive
vice-president and Carter had a colorful
past he was convicted of murder for
shooting a Mexican teenager when he
himself was a teenager Carter served
only two years and three years after his
release he joined the u.s. Border Patrol
at becoming its head in 1950 he even
bragged about his all-out war
undocumented Mexicans in a 1954
interview with the LA Times and it was
that same Carter that led the NRA
evolution from supporting gun control to
a newfound unconditional love for the
Second Amendment with Carter at the head
of the NRA membership tripled in the
following years and here is where it
gets interesting
the NRA started lobbying Congress for
years until it passed the firearm owners
Protection Act of 1986 that act softened
some of the regulations introduced in
1968 Gun Control Act the same act that
the NRA had actually supported but the
Act included an amendment that further
tightened the restrictions on machine
guns and a lot of NRA members weren't
too impressed and so they left when the
Brady handgun Violence Prevention Act
was introduced and signed into law by
Bill Clinton in 1993 the NRA fought back
they were successful in their lobbying
easing some of the restrictions
introduced in the bill that wasn't
enough for the NRA after the Brady Bill
was signed into law they funded lawsuits
across several states claiming that it
was unconstitutional that fight against
gun regulation led to a major surge in
the NRA membership meaning fighting gun
control was good for business but it
wasn't only because of rising membership
numbers in the early 90s Wayne LaPierre
was elected as the NRA executive vice
president stand up and show him you're
ready to fight and where did it win and
he was critical in fostering close
financial ties to the gun industry ties
so close that the NRA has been accused
of acting as more of a pro gun industry
organization than how it defines itself
as a civil rights organization and the
NRA ensures gun sales by spending
millions of dollars lobbying Congress
but I'm gonna get to that in just a
minute but first I want to explain how
the gun industry in large part bankrolls
the NRA and it's really crazy how it
does it let's start with the golden ring
of freedom program it was created in
2005 by Lapierre in order to reach out
to its richest members for bigger checks
and those richest members included
corporate partners from the gun industry
who between 2005 and 2013 donated
between 19 and 60 million dollars to the
organization in addition to donations
there are a growing number of NRA
program sponsored by gun manufacturers
for example in 2011 Thurmond rugger
launched the one
gun challenge a campaign to sell 1
million guns with one dollar from each
purchase going to the NRA but there's
more and Lee can break that down
companies likes
Sturm Ruger Smith & Wesson they actually
disclose to investors that on a
quarterly basis they provide millions of
dollars to the NRA as part of their
operating expenses so when they're doing
their own audits saying that they've got
to pay for staff and other upkeep they
actually include regular contributions
to the NRA now the NRA is putting a lot
of the money that it's received whether
from gun manufacturers or membership
fees towards lobbying Congress when gun
control legislation does come to
Congress they have direct lobbyists
people who walk the halls of Congress
talking to lawmakers they have their
membership base making calls to Congress
and directly meeting with legislators
and most importantly they also have the
threat of television advertisements when
a lawmaker threatens to vote for a gun
control the NRA can air tens of millions
of dollars in advertisements in their
district and that scares away a lot of
lawmakers from enacting meaningful gun
control legislation I'm the National
Rifle Association of America and I'm
freedom's safest place and the proof is
in the gun powder now even though a
large part of the NRA raise revenue
comes from its membership fees it
doesn't really represent the people it
says it does a 2017 Pew Research study
found that among Republican gun owners
more than half of NRA members are in
favor of instituting background checks
for private gun sales and that's
Republicans who own guns who say their
NRA members attitudes towards gun
control policy are shifting in the
United States there's more and more
support for background checks limiting
access to guns for people on watch lists
of people with mental illnesses and more
than half of gun owners support a
federal database for tracking gun sales
but it doesn't seem that the NRA has any
interest in backing away from its pro
gun industry position any time soon so
we usually only talk about gun control
whenever there's a major mass shooting
in the United States but gun violence is
actually way more prevalent than that
and did you guys know by the way about
the NRA shift in the 1970s when it went
from being so pro-gun
control to so unconditionally in love
with the second amendment let us know in
the comments and let us know what else
you want us to cover when it comes to
the gun control conversation in the
United States and come back next Sunday
when we come at you with another great
video